thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video
the world's climate is changing because
of the actions of humanity and this is
having a few knock-on effects among
other things it's disrupting the way
humans live their lives and making them
poorer it's estimated that if climate
change continues unabated it will have
reduced global gdp in the year 2100 by
37
the cost of climate change in 2021 alone
has been estimated at 170 billion
dollars and those people who have
contributed the least to this problem
those living in the global south and the
youth of today are those who are bearing
the brunt of it so you and your
descendants are being made poorer not
through your actions but through the
actions of others
doesn't sound very fair and what do we
do when things don't sound fair
we ask for justice
did someone say justice climate change
is such a huge problem that no one tool
exists that's powerful enough to solve
it on its own there is no silver bullet
to stop climate change what there is is
silver buckshot
throw everything at the problem every
tool at our disposal in an effort to
solve it and as this is a problem that
affects humans one of the tools at our
disposal is the framework that we've
communally agreed on to settle
grievances in other words the law and
for the past several decades people have
been doing this litigation has been
leveled at fossil fuel companies car
manufacturers energy supplies
governments and many more over a
thousand climate-related lawsuits have
been filed in the past six years alone
the majority of which are unsurprisingly
in the lawsuit capital of the world the
united states of america but while there
have been many many lawsuits few have
been successful which is kind of odd
because we know what causes climate
change the emission of greenhouse gases
like carbon dioxide and methane so if an
entity which could be a corporation like
exxon or a government like the
government of australia is known to be
responsible for a chunk of emissions
then we can say that they have changed
the climate and thus are responsible for
the damage caused if only it were that
simple unfortunately though i'm not a
lawyer so i don't have the knowledge to
explain to you quite why it's not that
simple
but i do just so happen to have
youtube's lawyer on speed dial i regret
to inform you that to date environmental
lawsuits have had very little success in
preventing climate change or redressing
the changes to the planet that have
already occurred and there are some very
good reasons for that in the u.s legal
system and really most of the legal
systems that follow in the english
tradition there are a number of
requirements that you have to meet
before you're able to file a lawsuit and
these types of environmental lawsuits
are incredibly difficult to actually
prosecute or move forward
first
generally a plaintiff to be able to sue
someone has to show injury in fact and
the injury in fact requirement requires
that
what the harm that you have suffered is
concrete and particularized
and it's not conjectural or hypothetical
so in other words even if
there are going to be real concrete
harms in the future you have to show
that you have suffered them in the
present or in the past on top of that
the injury that the plaintiff has
suffered needs to be actually
redressable by the court in other words
the court needs to be able to solve your
problem and
climate change that affects the entire
world
is not necessarily the type of thing
that any single court can solve or
provide damages for and then perhaps the
most important requirement generally to
being able to sue someone or something
is that the plaintiff has to show a
causal connection between the injury and
the conduct complained of in other words
it has to be fairly traceable to the
defendant's particular actions and when
it comes to climate change or the
environment this is particularly
difficult imagine you have a homeowner
who suffers damages related to a fire if
you can prove that someone started the
fire by lighting a match and setting
everything on fire that's probably not
hard to prove
in terms of the causal connection
now imagine you have two people both
with matches who set a fire at exactly
the same time that fire combines into
one fire and then it burns down
someone's house well now that's a little
bit harder but imagine still that you
have a thousand different people all
with matches setting a fire at the same
time
showing that your damages are related to
any one particular person it might not
be impossible but now it's getting more
dangerous then on top of it imagine you
have a situation where
i set up a rube goldberg machine that at
the end of it lights a match and starts
the fire now i don't actually start the
marble that sets the whole thing in
motion but somebody else does now who's
at fault is it the person that built the
rube goldberg machine or is it the
person that actually set it in motion
every time you get to a level of
abstraction it gets harder and harder to
be able to show a causal connection now
imagine in the climate change context
when you're dealing with say carbon
dioxide a metric ton of carbon dioxide
on its own probably has zero effect but
when you add thousands if not millions
of polluters all adding carbon dioxide
or methane well together that might
create some of the things that we're
talking about but maybe not alone so how
do you get damages from one particular
person who might be polluting when
there's thousands and thousands of other
people who have to contribute in order
for that to make a difference it's a
really really thorny question when it
comes to suing someone and trying to
stop it the problem with many lawsuits
to date is that they've focused on
emissions to date and thus the impact
that corporations and governments have
already had on the climate but here's
the thing
emissions are still ongoing and
unfortunately are going to continue into
the near future at the very least but
that means there's a whole different
possible category of lawsuit instead of
focusing on the past
focusing on holding corporations and
governments responsible for future
changes to the climb a landmark ruling
took place in 2015 in the netherlands
when a court ordered the dutch
government to cut its greenhouse gas
emissions as a failure to do so would
contribute to a climate that would pose
a quote serious degree of danger to
dutch citizens a ruling that was later
upheld by the dutch supreme court to
quote joanna setzer an expert in climate
litigation at the grantham institute for
the first time a court had recognized
that a government violates its duty of
care for citizens if it doesn't do
enough to curb emissions this meant a
lot from a legal point of view and since
that case strengthened by the precedent
and by the paris agreement and the
ipcc's fifth and now sixth assessment
reports more and more courts are ruling
in favor of climate-based plaintiffs and
as we strengthen our understanding of
both the causes of and effects of
climate change the type of litigation
brought to court is broadening
corporations are increasingly finding
themselves targeted by lawsuits that
aren't interested in gross carbon
emissions but things like green washing
corporations overselling the actions
they're taking to limit their
environmental impact or just outright
deception governments are also being
targeted in different more precise ways
such as seeking to remove specific
subsidies for the fossil fuel industry
or challenging permits being granted for
fossil fuel extraction or for the
expansion of airports though yeah that's
a pretty sore point for me in the
bristol area right now we can be pretty
confident that these strategic lawsuits
and their mirror image those filed by
individuals or corporations seeking to
prevent climate-based action will only
get more common in the next few years
honestly in terms of maximizing the
probability of success for using the
legal system
your best bet is probably changing the
law the things that i've talked about
are bedrock principles of litigation and
i don't think those things are going to
change anytime soon but
you can always write a law that allows
people to file suit that changes some of
those requirements the things that i've
been talking about are sort of the
default positions of the legal system
they exist well there isn't a contrary
law but that's the thing laws can be
changed and when you pass a law and
enact a statute well that changes the
default position of the legal system and
it would probably be pretty easy for
various governments to institute laws
that would allow someone to have
standing to file these kinds of lawsuits
governments could also give the power to
regulatory agencies to file suit on
behalf of the government so there are
certainly lots of ways for the default
position of the legal system to change
but at the moment given the default
rules it would be very very difficult so
you know
call your congressperson this is of
course a theme in climate change
generally speaking entire systems not
just the details in them need to change
from how we heat our homes to how
international trade is done but
especially with the dutch 2015 case
providing a legal precedent i am and
some environmental lawyers are growing
in confidence that more legal successes
lie in the near future climate
litigation will increasingly form part
of the silver buckshot used to try and
prevent catastrophic climate change this
century and if the past few years are
anything to go by it's going to be an
effective tool and yes winning a lawsuit
doesn't mean that emissions will fall
you have to enforce the ruling and yes
the whole system could frankly do with
an overhaul but
all the same
i never thought i'd say this
i think i'm
starting to like lawyers
thank you i was very lucky to have devin
collaborate with me on this project if
you'd like to see more from him check
out his legal videos on youtube or if
you'd rather watch his content without
any ads including some additional
exclusive videos such as his recent
episode on rights you absolutely should
be using as an american then check out
his channel on nebula as a matter of
fact you could check out exclusive
videos from me on nebula as well such as
my recent video on how norway became the
electric vehicle capital of the world
nebula as you've probably heard by now
is the streaming service owned and
operated by a huge team of educational
youtubers including me here we upload
the videos that we upload to youtube but
with extra content and without any ads
at all no pre-roll ads no ads in the
videos themselves it's the thoughtful
educational part of youtube with
creators like ali abdal are changing
climate and medlife crisis but better
there's no ads you can download videos
and watch them offline and by watching a
creator you directly financially support
them and help them make more content you
can get access by signing up with our
partners curiositystream who curate the
finest library of documentaries on the
internet they have thousands of
professionally produced titles such as
climate for a few degrees less about the
struggle to prevent global warming
reaching catastrophic levels available
at your fingertips by signing up at
curiositystream.com
simon clark you get access to all of
this extra content from your favorite
indie creators on nebula and a 26
discount it works out at just 14.79 for
an entire year or just over one dollar a
month for the version of youtube you
already watch but better and access to
thousands of brain improving
documentaries that's curiositystream.com
simon clark with thanks to
curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video thank you so much
for watching this video and of course
thank you so much to devon from league
of legal for collaborating with me on
this i've been watching devin's videos
for years if you haven't checked him out
before please do watch his videos
they're great this was a dream collab
for me if you'd like to watch something
next here's one of devin's videos here's
one of mine you can sign up for
curiosity stream down here and if you
aren't already please do subscribe to my
channel there's a button just just down
there if you enjoyed the video please do
pop it a like and that just leaves me to
say thank you again for watching i'll
see you in the next one